glitches facts secrets and more like
usual i've got a bit of everything for
you today if you like seeing this series
continue let us know with a like it lets
me know to keep doing this for you
alright here we go
have you noticed that pretty much every
enemy with the bow and arrow like humans
closes one eye while aiming this is
pretty standard for looking down a sight
to focus your aim but what's even more
interesting is that nintendo did their
homework and did not do this with the
lizolfos
lizolfos are designed after chameleons
and can't blink because they have no
proper eyelids and unlike other animals
have monocular vision as opposed to our
binocular vision meaning each eye works
independently and can go in two
different directions but when locked
onto prey both their eyes will lock onto
the target and strike with their tongue
or in this case with an arrow to your
face
pretty interesting
if you're a fan of glitches in breath of
the wild the holy grail of glitches has
recently been discovered user zx robin
discovered the most broken inventory
duplication method so far called ist or
inventory slot transfer this does
basically everything that memory storage
does but is easier to perform more
complex to understand and is capable of
much much more it's so powerful that it
can easily corrupt your file and make
some items unusable the very basic
explanation is to hold smuggle items
into your hands sell them off hold one
more item then toss it on the ground
this creates invisible slots that when
reloading duplicates parts of your
inventory this allows a bow of light on
master mode mass duplication of almost
anything you want such as fairies to an
ungodly amount to make link basically
invincible inventory corruption
transferring durability and definitely
more this new glitch has many
possibilities that can be pushed very
far in many situations so we'll likely
see more of this in the future
cooking is a staple of breath of the
wild and visiting a cooking pot was
always a straightforward affair
just toss the food in the pot but did
you know that this mechanic can be
blocked if there's something in the way
that's blocking ingredients from getting
into the cooking pot it actually won't
let you cook and instead we'll roll off
the sides of the pot there's a theory
that this may be leftover code of
nintendo's original idea of using an
actual lid on the cooking pot that could
have blocked you from throwing food into
the pot unless it was opened but that's
unconfirmed this is a subtle detail but
when you approach an npc you get a
lock-on system that usually tells you
their name but this doesn't show up if
you've never met them before so you'll
first have to introduce yourself then
you'll remember their name and it'll
show up above their head the next time
you see them did you know that nintendo
has been sneakily updating your map
behind your back as you play the game
you probably never even noticed it but
some major terrain changes reflect in
real time on the map such as terrytown
being built one building at a time
and when you launch yunobo into the
bridge of elden to knock it down
here's a nifty way to cheese your way
over shockable areas if you fire a shock
arrow where you're going to walk your
electricity overrides the damaging shock
and lets you walk on it for a split
second
this is a strange design choice but in
the official compendium all enemies are
organized by tears while choo choos are
organized by elemental type there are
multiple tiers of each element that are
not categorized and instead all of them
are just called chuchu the technical
name for these were junior chuchu middle
chuchu and senior chuchu but that's not
their official names there were plans to
include middle and senior choo-choos of
different elements but by the looks of
it they scrapped that idea for brevity
and make less clutter in the compendium
these photos of middle and senior choo
choos were early versions with colors
that were much different than what you
see today now let's go over some hidden
damage boosts you may have never noticed
most players know that the ancient armor
full set has the ancient weapon attack
boost and a guardian resist buff but did
you know that the diamond circlet has a
small 20 ancient weapon attack boost by
itself as well even midna's helmet which
has the same property boosts ancient
weapon attack as well but we're not done
yet even more pieces of gear completely
unrelated to ancient technology have
this perk this includes the ruby circlet
sapphire circlit and topaz earrings
[Music]
but for some reason amber and opal
earrings are excluded from this buff
wolf link is a nice buddy to have but
doesn't do too much damage to help out
in battle doing a measly 15 damage per
bite and if he takes damage during
battle any food you give him will help
him heal hearts including obviously low
and mid tier meats but high tier meats
such as raw hole birds or raw gourmet
meat are special he will eat these no
matter what even if his hearts are full
and you can see wolf link howell ready
for battle
attacking an enemy now does a whopping
75 damage that's a times 5 multiplier
increase in damage compared to before
that's almost as much as a base savage
lano crusher per byte so now you know
how you can upgrade your little teams
into a chad doge
do you know how tebba holsters his bow
you'll never actually see it because you
never see him fire his bow but if
attacked by enemies you can see him
holster his falcon bow upside down on
his back we don't quite know if this is
the true way he puts it away because it
was never meant to be seen but according
to age of calamity he holsters it
differently so we're not sure which one
is true bolson construction leaves her
mark on everything they work on in
terrytown and hoteno village if you look
closely this includes their logos on
many signs and doors this text signature
everywhere which says builders on
bolson's personal work hammer and even
your sledgehammer you've been carrying
around this entire time did you know
that different races have different run
speeds this clip shows a gerudo and a
goron running for cover from the rain
but if the gerudo is behind the goron
she's stuck behind him because he's
running too slow but if she's in front
of the goron their distance becomes
larger and larger because she can run
faster something nintendo didn't have to
think about but they did anyways
have you ever been in a situation where
you threw a weapon or shot a sword beam
and thought am i just bad or am i
missing these shots well there's a very
subtle bug that nintendo didn't fix when
you have the magnesis rune selected for
some reason anything thrown swings to
the upper right so no it's not just you
some players know that when it rains
some areas form large puddles this is
created by a very simple but effective
mechanic which is simple water asset
called field object puddle slowly moves
up to clip through the ground to
simulate a growing puddle then slowly
goes back down to simulate evaporating
water simple but genius
there are several special shield
modifiers you can pick up along your
journey such as guard up and durability
up sure these are useful but there's one
secret modifier in the game's code that
nintendo never released the surf up
modifier this would have given any
shield the surfing ability better than
the shield of mine's eye but slightly
worse than the ancient shield it's
unknown why this was removed but i wish
it was left in the game during the
development of breath of the wild there
were multiple types of liquid terrain
from basic water lava mud ice water
spring water and more but there's one
type that didn't make the final cut
poison water this had similar properties
to standard water but with the obvious
factor that it would not be pleasant to
step into user waikuteru in a mod
restored these original properties from
the game's code from nintendo to see
what it would be like but did you know
that this actually exists in the base
game under our feet the entire time at
the banta tower and at dragon bone mire
and the strange patch outside the trial
of the sword
just like in the base code it won't
allow you to use cryonis on it in this
case though this poison water is
harmless but there are patches in breath
of the wild that do actually hurt you
such as this patch here at dragon bone
mire and this specific patch in the
trial of the sword where they replaced
poison damage with lava damage as a
substitute since it was removed
[Music]
what was your favorite thing you learned
this time let us know in the comments
below and if you're interested in this
new glitch we'll be making a guide on
how ist works in the future so stay
tuned right here on gamespot
[Music]
you